foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and
we forget that it's a lie
all right ladies and Gentlemen The Game
of Thrones and A Song of Ice and Fire
Universe got a hell of a lot more
exciting thanks to the breaking news
from variety now according to variety's
exclusive article HBO is finally in the
works of developing a brand new Game of
Thrones series about aegon the Conqueror
and let me be the first one to say it
it's about damn time now I want to show
you what variety said then I will give
my thoughts at the end of the video
their new article says a new Game of
Thrones series about aegon targaryen's
conquest of Westeros is being actively
discussed at HBO variety has learned
exclusively from their sources as the
show is in its early stages no writer
has currently been hired those sources
say that the search is underway as HBO
is looking to move forward and get it
into development their sources also say
that there may be a feature component to
the project I.E HBO and Warner Brothers
would also make a feature film that
would then lead into the series although
nothing has been set in stone just yet
so as you can see variety sources are
saying HP yo wants to make a feature
film about aegon the Conqueror that
would help set up their new show now
this is very exciting news they go on to
say the show would tell the story of how
aegon and his sister wives vicenya and
rhaenys use their army and their three
dragons to conquer six of the Seven
Kingdoms on Westeros with the exception
of Dorne in doing so aegon became the
first king of Westeros and first to sit
on the iron throne and the founder of
the Targaryen Dynasty those events
happened roughly 300 years before the
events of Game of Thrones now I actually
think they should have made this show
first before they released House of the
Dragon I think if HBO wants to tell the
story of the history of House Targaryen
they should have started at the very
beginning when they first arrived in
Westeros a series about aegon would have
been a great setup for the show about
the dance of the Dragons it would have
shown how and why the targaryens ended
up in Westeros how they United the
kingdoms and ultimately how aegon and
his Dragon balerion the black dread made
the iron throne burn that has become so
iconic today if the film and show does
get made we will finally see valerion in
all of his glory I know many fans have
been wanting to see this dragon ever
since Game of Thrones first shown us his
massive Scar in The Dungeons of the red
keep now as of right now HBO hasn't
confirmed this information variety also
says this would be the latest Westeros
bass series at HBO following the global
success of Game of Thrones HBO has
started developing a number of shows set
in The Amazing universe created by
Author George R Martin of the numerous
projects announced over the years the
only one to move forward to date has
been House of the dragon that show aired
its first season in August of last year
earning a speedy season 2 renewal less
than a week after it launched as you all
know the second season of House of the
Dragon is currently in development as
they're only days away from filming the
scenes now this move to expand the Game
of Thrones universe and potentially tie
in a film is not surprising as the show
remains one of the most valuable IPS in
the Warner Brothers Discovery Library
Legacy Media companies have also been
working for some time on building
interconnected film and TV universes
around their biggest titles and that's
with Disney's Marvel Cinematic Universe
being the biggest example now I must say
this is very exciting news as I'm sure
most of you already know many of us have
been wanting a series about aegon and
his sisters for many many years now it
looks like HBO is not only working on a
show about aegon but a feature-length
film as well it does seem HBO is all in
on making sure the Game of Thrones
Universe stays alive and relevant for
many years to come now you gotta
remember HBO hasn't confirmed the
information but variety always seems to
have amazing sources when it comes to
what's happening behind the scenes with
all the Game of Thrones successor shows
as of right now they say HBO still
hasn't found the writer for the show or
the movie so even if it does actually
happen it will still be a while before
we see either one error on HBO or HBO
Max now the good thing is we least know
what else they have been working on and
developing within the Song of Ice and
Fire Universe although we have heard a
lot of news regarding the Jon Snow show
it does seem HBO's main focus is on
telling the history of House Targaryen
as I've always said I will be looking
forward to any new show or movie they
make about A Song of Ice and Fire but as
a fan of the many different aspects of
The Amazing Story I do hope they still
make some other shows about the
different families and locations
throughout George RR Martin's Incredible
Universe I still want to see the Jon
Snow series get made along with the
movie and the show about aegon and his
sisters if everything does work out we
might see Westeros on our televisions
for the next decade or Beyond like I
always say I will be here making videos
about everything happening every step of
the way well it's official my friends
The Game of Thrones fandom just got a
hell of a lot more interesting make sure
you subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything that's happening with
House of the Dragon The Winds of Winter
and all of the other Game of Thrones
shows HBO has has been developing let me
know what all of you think about this
new information down below are you
excited for a show about aegon or would
you rather see something else first
leave me some of your thoughts and once
again I have to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
foreign
[Music]